this episode of the Y files is brought
to you by private internet access
[Music]
on June 30th 1908 a mysterious explosion
shook the remote Siberian region of
tunguska the blast flattened 80 million
trees across 800 square miles every
plant every animal every insect in the
blast radius was vaporized the Shockwave
was felt as far away as England it
looked like a comet impact yet no crater
was found and no debris was discovered
scientists still can't explain what
happened but at that exact moment on the
other side of the world Nikola Tesla was
conducting his latest experiment
transmitting massive amounts of
electricity through the atmosphere Tesla
activated the generators in his lab and
fired up Warden Cliff tower for one
final dramatic test and sent millions of
volts of electricity into the sky after
the test was complete Tesla looked at
the readings on his equipment and said
uh-oh
[Music]
inventor and Visionary Nikola Tesla was
known for his groundbreaking ideas that
shaped the world of science and
technology however there was one
invention that remained shrouded in
mystery and controversy a weapon of
unimaginable power he called it the
Tesla gun but it became known by a more
ominous name the Tesla death ray Tesla's
fascination with electricity led him to
conceive of a weapon that could destroy
entire armies from a great distance the
science behind the death ray was based
on Tesla's experiments with high
frequency electricity Tesla believed
that energy could be transmitted
wirelessly over great distances the
weapon was designed as a large Tesla
coil which consisted of a series of
capacitors that could store vast amounts
of electrical energy the energy was then
released in a concentrated beam which
could be directed toward a Target oh it
sounds a lot like the Death Star it does
but I don't think that's be so proud of
this technological Terror you've
constructed the ability to destroy a
planet is insignificant when it comes to
the power of the fourth don't try to
frighten us with your sorcerer's ways
Lord hecklefish You're a sad Devotion to
that ancient religion has not helped you
convince more people to join patreon or
giving you Clairvoyance enough to see
what videos the YouTube algorithm will
[Music]
release him yes you wish
Tesla wanted to create a weapon that
could be powered by a small portable
generator with enough power to destroy
anything in its path fleets of planes
fields of tanks and even entire cities
he described the potential of the death
ray as a device that would harness
unlimited free energy from the space all
around us I have harnessed the cosmic
rays and caused them to operate a molded
device this new power for driving of the
world's Machinery will be derived from
the energy which operates the universe
the cosmic energy which holds Central
source for the Earth is the Sun and
which is everywhere present in unlimited
quantities Tesla's reasons for inventing
the death ray were rooted in his strong
belief in World Peace he hoped that the
weapon would act as a deterrent to war
that if every nation possessed the
ability to destroy each other there'd be
no point in Waging War at all and this
Ultimate Weapon would usher in a new age
of peace all right like how this been
World Peace ever since the nuclear bomb
was invented sarcasm shop a bowling ball
this human eh obviously political and
military leaders were worried about
Tesla's invention wherever they could
they tried to interfere they prevented
him from getting patents they made it
difficult for him to receive funding it
became a priority to do anything and
everything possible to prevent Tesla
from creating this weapon but it didn't
matter what they did Tesla already built
it
in 1908 just months before the tunguska
event renowned Explorer Admiral Robert
Peary set out on an expedition to the
North Pole a feat that had never before
been accomplished well except for Stan
and his wifey in a tiny reindeer and
Rudolph and a whole buttload of elves
thanks for that helpful clarification
hey h-y-m-e despite the numerous
challenges Admiral Perry was determined
to reach the North Pole and make history
The Journey would not be easy the harsh
Arctic environment made the Expedition
incredibly difficult and dangerous the
team faced extreme cold blizzards and
unpredictable terrain despite these
risks Perry was determined to succeed
but he would need a new technology to
help him navigate the desolate region
this is where Nikola Tesla came in in
1904 Tesla developed a new type of radio
receiver that could detect signals from
the death ray and this receiver was used
by Admiral Peery during his North Pole
Expedition and was claimed that it
helped him navigate through the
Hazardous Arctic terrain but that was
1904. by 1906 Tesla's chief financial
backer JP Morgan was growing impatient
with Tesla and the lack of financial
return if JP Morgan withdrew funding
Tesla's plans would be ruined as the
relationship between Morgan and Tesla
began to sour Nikola Tesla knew he
needed to do something dramatic to
secure his funding and secure his future
Tesla knew the world was watching
Admiral Perry's expedition to the North
Pole and thought this was the perfect
opportunity to demonstrate the awesome
power of His invention he would fire a
bolt of energy toward ellsmere and light
up the skies creating the greatest light
show the world had ever seen just two
months before tunguska Tesla wrote this
this is not a dream even now Wireless
power plants could be constructed by
which in the region of the globe might
be rendered uninhabitable without
subjecting the population of other parts
to Serious danger or inconvenience at
the time of the tunguska blast in 1908
Perry was camped out at ellsmere Island
preparing for a final push to the pole
Tesla set period a cryptic message
saying the extreme cold and isolation
make the Arctic the perfect location for
this type of experiment Tesla told
period to watch the skies above the
tundra for a signal Perry asked Tesla
what kind of signal he should be looking
for Tesla told him that he'll know it
when he sees it uh-oh back at Warden
Cliff tower on the North Shore of Long
Island New York the Moment of Truth had
arrived Tesla took a deep breath and
activated the machine that would send
the charged particles coursing through
an intricate network of wires and coils
at first the tower generated a low hum
but the sound grew louder and louder
until it was a deafening Roar once the
machine was fully charged a beam of
light brighter than the sun shot out of
warden Cliff Tower and sliced through
the air for 10 or 15 seconds vast
amounts of energy poured into the
atmosphere then it suddenly stopped
Darkness followed and the only sound was
a crackling of static from the residual
electricity created by the machine Tesla
felt an intense Rush of exhilaration the
machine worked he knew his funding would
be secure and he could continue his work
but Tesla's excitement would last only a
few moments he looked at the readings on
his death ray machine it worked but it
worked too well rather than a dazzling
light show Tesla had created a massive
wave of energy a thousand times more
powerful than an atomic bomb this
immense power caused the energy beam to
overshoot its Target it didn't light up
the sky above ellsmere it made landfall
somewhere in Russia but even Tesla
didn't know how destructive his weapon
really was
foreign
I woke up to the sound of the earth
crumbling beneath my feet I could hear
the trees outside my cabin being ripped
from the ground and crashing down all
around me at first I thought it was an
earthquake but the air was filled with
the sound of the explosions and gunfire
something dark and terrible was
happening outside as I stumbled out of
my kitten and into the forest I could
see the sky lighting up with the fiery
orange glow it was like this sun had
risen in the middle of the night and the
air was thick with the smell of smoke
and burning wood suddenly there was a
blinding flash that illuminated the
entire forest and the sound of a
deafening boom that shook me to my core
I fell to the ground my ears ring you
with the force of the explosion and any
struggled to regain my bearings the
trees around me were torn from the
ground and I could hear the sound of
splintering wood and snapping branches
see Graham shook so violently that I
thought it might open up and swallow me
I could feel the Shockwave from the
blast hearing through the forest I saw
trees being flattened in all directions
and I was pelted with debris from the
explosion the ear was thick with dust
and Ash and it was getting harder and
hardened Breeze princess finally cleared
the forest was a Charged Wasteland the
trees had been ripped from the ground
and there was nothing left but stumps in
Ash the air was thick with the smell of
burning wood there were no sounds a
birds or insects or animals just easy
silence I never felt so alone in my
entire life
on June 30th 1908 a massive explosion
occurred in the remote tunguska region
of Siberia releasing an estimated 15
megatons of energy the explosion
flattened an area of over 800 square
miles no animal or plant in the blast
radius survived 80 million trees were
reduced to Cinders no birds or insects
had time to escape thousands of animals
on the ground were vaporized the
scientific Community still debates the
cause of the tunguska event some
theories suggest that it was caused by a
natural gas explosion or a nuclear
detonation caused by extraterrestrial
spacecraft oh get on but many people
believe it was a Nikola Tesla experiment
that got out of control the prevailing
theory is that the explosion was caused
by an air burst a large comet that
exploded in the Earth's atmosphere but
there are some problems with this Theory
eyewitnesses have reported seeing lights
in the sky both before and for days
after the event meteors don't do this
even as far away as England the sky was
lit up newspapers were flooded with
reports of night turning in today one
reporter said he was able to read a book
in the middle of the night using nothing
but the strange light in the sky
eyewitnesses also report the ground
shaking like an earthquake for a long
time before the impact one witness said
it was powerful enough to reduce a
skyscraper to Rubble the seismic
activity was enough to knock people off
their feet and the effects were felt all
over Europe as far away as the UK a
meteor air burst would look like a
streak of light or fire and then an
explosion this would last only a few
seconds but Reports say a wide beam of
light was in the sky for much longer
than
locals said the air got very cold at
first then the sky lit up brighter than
the Sun and suddenly the air was very
very hot also there's no meteor crater
or traces of meteorite in the area and
if you draw a line from Tesla's lab in
New York to Ellesmere Island and
continue that line you end up in Siberia
very close to if not the exact point of
impact the explosion happened at an
altitude of four or five miles this is
much higher than most meteor Air Bursts
luckily the Impact Zone happened in
Siberia one of the most remote places on
Earth yeah but what if this happened to
a city well if the tunguska event were
to occur over a major city it it would
be bad how bad
oh no here comes the scary music the
sudden explosion would generate a
massive shock wave that would rip
through the city like a tornado
demolishing buildings and all
infrastructure in its path the shock
wave would be followed by a searing
Fireball that would incinerate
everything leaving behind nothing but
smoldering Ash the sheer force of the
explosion would create a hurricane of
debris and shrapnel anything not firmly
attached to the ground would be thrown
into the air cars trucks boats planes
people the resulting Firestorm would
continue to spread fueled by the intense
heat and winds generated by the blast
streets and buildings would be consumed
by a raging Inferno trapping anyone who
would survived the initial blast in an
ocean of flames and smoke in the
aftermath of such an event the death
toll would be staggering in the millions
the City and surrounding landscape would
be unrecognizable as frightening as it
is that one man could create a device
that could wreak this kind of
Devastation it's even more more
frightening than another tunguska event
Could Happen anywhere at any time
without warning and if it does there's
nothing we can do to stop it
the death ray also known as the Tesla
gun was a weapon that was said to be
capable of destroying entire armies with
a single shot while Tesla's weapon is
still shrouded in mystery and
controversy the idea of a directed
energy weapon is based on sound
scientific principles so of course
modern militaries are developing that
same old story create technology that
kills as many people as possible then
profit from it maybe these weapons are
used to protect our freedom drink some
more Kool-Aid sheep the basic principle
of directed energy weapons or Dews is
the conversion of electrical energy into
an electromagnetic or particle beam
which is then directed toward the target
the type of energy used and the method
of delivery vary depending on the weapon
some tews use lasers some use microwaves
and others use particle beams for
example lasers work by emitting a
concentrated beam of light that can burn
blind or disable a Target microwave
weapons use high frequency
electromagnetic radiation to heat up or
damage the target particle beam weapon
use accelerated charged particles such
as electrons or protons to cause damage
the effectiveness of a directed energy
weapon depends on several factors the
power of the energy being the duration
of the beam and the distance between the
weapon and the target range is critical
especially if the target is moving
because the weapon has to be able to
track and maintain a lock directed
energy weapons are being deployed right
now they've been used to disable
missiles drones and other Airborne
threats as well as provide non-lethal
crowd control measures
oh Nikola Tesla had a deep understanding
of particle physics and electromagnetic
Theory his energy weapon used particles
the particles which could be electrons
protons or ions would be accelerated to
high speeds and focused in a beam using
powerful magnetic fields the beam would
then be directed at the Target where it
would cause massive damage but the idea
of a directed energy weapon was around
before Nikola Tesla but if anyone could
create it it was him though no one
officially saw it in use Tesla claimed
his prototype worked Tesla himself
fueled the speculation he wrote several
letters to the New York Times explaining
the potential of his invention as to
projecting wave energy to any particular
region of the globe this can be done by
my devices the spot at which the desired
of threat is to be produced can be
calculated very closely assuming the
accepted terrestrial measurements to be
correct but is this what really happened
at tunguska was the explosion the result
of a Tesla experiment gone awry like
many people believe or was it the result
of a meteor airborne first what would be
helpful is if we had modern evidence of
a large meteor air burst to help us
better understand guska we have it we do
it happened in 2013. and this time we
have video
and it's terrifying
[Music]
actually
on February 15 2013 a blinding flash of
light tore through the sky over the
Russian city of chelybinsk followed by a
deafening explosion That Shook the Earth
local residents were stunned terrified
and Confused the event which has since
become known as the chelyabins meteor
was one of the most dramatic and
mysterious events in recent history and
remains a testament to the scary power
of the universe the meteor that caused
the Chelyabinsk event was estimated to
be around 60 feet in diameter and
weighed over 10 000 tons it entered the
Earth's atmosphere at a speed of
approximately 19 kilometers per second
how fast is that in a number we can
actually understand 12 miles per second
or 43 000 miles per hour almost 60 times
the speed of sound yeah I understand
that and now I'm terrified the fireball
glowed 30 times brighter than the sun so
bright and so hot that people suffered
burns on their skin and damage to their
eyes the resulting explosion was
estimated to be equivalent to 5 500
kilotons of TNT making it one of the
most powerful non-nuclear explosions
ever recorded the shock wave shattered
Windows damaged over 1 000 buildings and
injured 1500 people unlike tunguska
scientists were able to study the Chely
events meteor in detail they found that
the meteor was likely a remnant of the
early solar system and had been
traveling through space for about four
and a half billion years before
colliding with Earth the Chely binsk
event also served as a wake-up call for
the scientific Community because nobody
saw it coming there was Zero warning
these types of meteor Air Bursts and
impacts happened every day whenever you
see a shooting star that's a small
meteor burning up in the atmosphere but
larger impacts happen pretty often too
every 10 or 15 years but they usually
happen over the ocean so we don't notice
but that's just dumb luck the dunguska
event was 10 000 times more powerful
than the one at chelybinsk enough to
easily wipe out a large city but the
chixier lube impact that happened 66
million years ago that wiped out about
75 percent of all species on Earth
including all the dinosaurs and that
wasn't even the biggest asteroid to hit
the earth not even close so it's not a
matter of if it'll happen again it's
just a matter of when now fortunately
scientists are taking this threat
seriously NASA's double asteroid
redirection test or Dart Mission
conducted a successful test on September
26 2022 it intentionally slammed into
the asteroid called dimorphos and
altered its orbit by 33 minutes now
that's not very much but when
considering the vast distances of space
a 33-minute change could be the
difference between an asteroid passing
by harmlessly or wiping out all life on
Earth there are over 1 million asteroids
in our solar system and NASA is
currently tracking over 30 000
near-earth asteroids or neas that are
potential threats still that's only 90
percent of the dangerous objects zipping
around the solar system because look the
dinosaurs didn't have a space program
well what Lee amazing people have a
space program everybody knows that oh
are lizard people going to protect us
from asteroids no way lizard people want
an asteroid it'll save them a lot of
work when most humans are wiped out but
then they can enslave the rest is well
that's reassuring I don't worry lizard
people are known to be strict but fair
overlords the universe is full of
Wonders but also full of dangers we have
to do everything we can and deploy every
possible resource to ensure that we
don't experience another jelly events or
another tunguska or another chick
shiloop Our Fate is up to us and up to
the illicit people please don't step on
my lines when I'm trying to be dramatic
and hopeful oh excuse me you have to
acknowledge illicit people
and even if they did they should be more
worried about asteroids
[Music]
foreign
the Tesla Death Ray and the potential
connection between the two is an example
of the power of human imagination and
the endless possibilities of Science and
Technology while the theory that the
death ray caused the explosion Remains
unproven the story serves as a reminder
of the potential that scientific
discovery and technological innovation
have to change the world the legacy of
Nikola Tesla is not just in his
inventions but also in his vision for
the future Tesla was a forward thinker
who believed that Science and Technology
held the key to a brighter and a better
world he once said We crave for New
Sensations but soon become indifferent
to them the wonders of yesterday are
today common occurrences now that's
certainly true look at smartphones these
devices are marvels of engineering
packed with Advanced sensors processors
and software that allow us to
communicate learn and entertain
ourselves in ways that were unimaginable
just a few decades ago yet despite their
incredible capabilities we treat them as
if they were as mundane as a toaster or
vacuum cleaner the same could be said
for many other Innovations from
self-driving cars and drones to virtual
reality and artificial intelligence
we've become so accustomed to the
incredible power and potential of these
technologies that we sometimes forget
how amazing they truly are but when
Tesla said the wonders of yesterday are
today common occurrences he wasn't
scolding us that was a dream that he had
that technology specifically his
technology would be available to
everyone everywhere in the world Tesla's
vision for the future was that Science
and Technology would improve The Human
Condition he saw a world where energy
was abundant and cheap where people
could communicate instantly across vast
distances and where machines could do
the work that humans once had to do by
hand he believed that these advancements
could lead to a better and more
prosperous world for all and he was
right seventy percent of all products We
Touch can be traced back to Tesla
including 100 of products that use
electricity his ideas continue to
inspire Electric cars solar power and
wireless communication owed debt to
Tesla in the end the story of the
tunguska event and Tesla's death ray is
not just about the potential for
Destruction and chaos but also about the
incredible power of human Ingenuity and
the Limitless potential of Science and
Technology Tesla said the present is
theirs the future of which I really work
is mine but because of him the future
now belongs to all of us
hope we use it wisely
[Music]
what's this
um I need to work remotely for a while
well you told me people aren't
productive working remotely don't rub
that
[Music]
I got myself in a little trouble
what websites were you on that's not
important right now let's
hold you always use a private internet
access VPN when doing anything online
are you crazy I know
more privacy features than any other
software and real-time protection from
malware and trackers I know I use it on
my PC to change my IP address so I can
watch movies that aren't available in
America it's just I was using my phone
and I forgot Mac PC iOS Android it
doesn't matter what device you're using
private internet access keeps your data
safe and gives you better privacy
protection than any other VPN out there
what were you thinking I know I really
screwed up this time by the way where
are you yeah I can't tell you that let's
just say there are several governments
that would like to see me batting
that sounds delicious actually quit
screwing around you better tell all the
humans to get a VPN the Men in Black are
keeping tips on everyone who watches
this stupid show good idea if you go to
piavpn.com Y files you save 83 and can
protect your data for as little as two
bucks a month it's worth it trust me and
if you're not happy for any reason
there's a 30-day money-back guarantee no
questions asked that's
what was that oh no I think they found
me
was that French are you in France not
exactly
[Music]
look I gotta go I have to put on my
disguise you your disguise yeah uh p i a
vpn.com y files sweet day so late
grab a VPN now and don't make the same
mistake I did
film sexy did you just say you're a
femme sexy don't break my horns this is
serious
[Music]
foreign
thanks so much for hanging out with us
today my name is AJ that's hacklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe share comment that stuff
really helps the channel like most
topics we cover here today's was
recommended by you so if there's a story
you'd like to see or learn more about go
to the yfiles.com tips special thanks to
our patrons who make this channel
possible we couldn't do this without you
guys I'm constantly amazed by your
generosity and grateful that you're out
there and if you'd like to support the
channel and become part of our community
consider becoming a member on patreon or
grab something from the Wi-Fi store but
whatever you do don't buy a crab Cat
Coffee Mug why not because that's how
you summon a crab kit oh there's no such
thing
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
thank you